a hero welcomed back home
images of happy soldiers returning from
the front are broadcast almost every day
on ukrainian television
but pictures like these are not shown
they were recorded just a few weeks ago
as ukrainian soldiers were surrounded by
rebels near ilovaisk
it was a brutal battle a bloodbath
medic michael gulac was in the thick of
it
he says of the 400 ukrainian troops
fighting in that battle only a third
survived
he himself was injured
we don't have proper weapons or vehicles
i belong to a special unit of the
interior ministry and we were taken to
the front in a large taxi a taxi without
breaks
my colleague colga was the driver and i
sat next to him providing cover with my
machine gun
the battle at iloveisk was the ukrainian
forces biggest defeat so far
mishael believes it was only god who
enabled him to survive not his gun or
his generals
there were 250 volunteers in our
battalion only 90 said they were
prepared to fight
the rest refused not because they were
afraid but because they were smart lots
more would have fought if they were
properly armed we barely had enough
weapons to defend ourselves let alone
launch an offensive
for days michael and his colleague
looked after the survivors of the route
they conducted operations in makeshift
facilities and public buildings
using supplies that were decades old
outside desperate troops waited for a
convoy to be evacuated to safety
many never made it
we only had two doctors for every 100
men in the battalion
the regulations say that there has to be
at least 10 doctors for every 100
soldiers
there was no transport to evacuate the
wounded
we couldn't carry them on stretchers for
20 kilometers
i felt so sorry for the wounded i
stroked them and told them everything
would be all right
even though i knew some of them would
die within minutes
what are you supposed to do this is war
a war that is still going on in spite of
the ceasefire
and a war in which a safe homecoming is
something many never get to experience
you